communities
foreign
in such an
option on the up here on the podium we
have the heads of Delegation from the
osce elementary assembly from the
Parliamentary assembly of the Council of
Europe and from the osc office for
Democratic institutions and human rights
we'll begin with some brief statements
from the podium and then should there be
plenty of time for your question
I first give the floor to Michelle Guild
link
who is special coordinator and leader of
the short-term oversee Observer mission
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen welcome thank you
very much for joining us
we are doing together here and we will
have a couple of remarks as Katya sector
at the beginning by thanking you for all
this press conference not only joining
it but also also following the whole
development
and following
two important
witness yesterday
it is always for us an honor to be here
in this wonderful Hospital country where
we are not observing elections for the
first time but therefore
because it's so tragic
please allow me to start by expressing
our condolences on the tragic loss of
life
we're so many lives have been lost that
occur following the earthquakes earlier
this year this
this observation a special one
conscience of the losses the Turkish
people
and this is not
all of us observers we're so impressed
by the overwhelming journal in this
election
in this Centenary year of the Turkish
Republic the Turkish people have clearly
demonstrated their commitment and their
willingness to having the decisive sale
in the future of this country
now let me come to the conclusions so
the main conclusions which we will share
with you today more completement
statement as you know will be available
and published
immediately after our statements
and therefore
let me summarize for money
view the most important points if the
general elections held in the wake of
the devastating earthquakes voters had a
choice between genuine political
Alternatives and voter participation was
high
but the incumbent and the ruling parties
enjoyed an unjustified Advantage
including through biased media
so they're very genuine political
alternatives are limited on Level
Playing Field
in addition to this the continued
restrictions on fundamental freedoms of
assembly Association and
just hindered the participation of some
opposition politicians and parties civil
society and Independent Media in the
election process
nonetheless we found that the campaign
itself was competitive and largely free
for most contestants but it was
characterized by intense polarization
and marred by hardship rhetoric
instances of misuse of administrative
resources and the pressure and
intimidation faced by especially one
opposition party
the election Administration technically
managed
managed that there was a lack of
transparency and communication as well
as concern over its independence
measures measures designed to facilitate
registration
and voting for earthquake effective
citizens were limited placing an
additional burden on these voters to
exercise the emerging rights
election day was generally well
organized and it says possibly
positively by all servers however
instances of deficient implementation of
certain procedures particularly during
voting and County Reloaded
that's the overall picture but I want to
particularly highlight a few background
topics that broadcast
it's important that that and Report the
background information that will
practice
Freedom Assembly Association
are restricted by legislation and that
the independence of the Judiciary
remains a concern
while we note positively that the
long-standing recommendation to lower
the Parliamentary threshold was
addressed many other important
recommendations remain uninterest
joining to the politicals yes the
technical registration of candidates
technical registration was managed
inclusively but still part of the
solution proceedings against the
psychological opposition party impeded
its participation
at the criminal prosecution of San
Francisco
patients may also have hindered their
candidacy
politically motivated interference in
the electoral process is the
international commitments made by third
year for example in the ose or under the
European Convention of Human Rights this
applied also to some very prominent
individuals including the mayor of
Istanbul business
all in all let me sum up the inner
Spirit of friendship and deep affection
to the Turkish people into this country
we were observing and we were trying to
do to the best of our authorities
observation
and coming up let me say these were
competitive but still limited elections
as the criminalization of some political
forces including the Detention of
several opposition politicians prevented
full political pluralism and Imperial
that is why we said political
interference and director process is not
in line with turkey's International
commitment that is only measure
global history
for the preliminary results we have seen
this election is not over we will
continue to observe also the second
round of
forward to releasing
for thank you very much
thank you very much we now move on to
French who heads the delegation from
pace
thank you very much you learn good
afternoon so I refer to the text as well
but in addition I would like to say that
we were here as a council of Europe with
39 39
members for the short-term election
observation I would like to thank the
osce order for the very good cooperation
because at the end we are in a way
depending on on the profit professional
and internality of this organization
um so I have to inform you that we were
invited by the authorities
um of this country due to the situation
that turkey is under monitoring uh in
the uh parliamentary assembly of the
Council of Europe
we are prepared for sure as well for a
possible second round
um but we were here already for
pre-election mission two days and we had
the opportunity to have a lot of
interlocutors from all about the society
the governmental parties the opposition
party civil societies
um and so on and so on and we have the
opportunity to meet the central
electoral Council what unfortunately was
this time not not possible so the
country
I have a lot of democratic challenges
for sure and we have a lot of
statements in our organization the
Council of Europe referring to this but
nevertheless I have to say as well like
Mr Ling that we were impressed by the
high turnout in this election and by the
possibility even when it's problematic
to run and
to have an election campaign for some
parties and some politicians that there
was the possibility of a competition you
could feel it at the election day that
the Turkish democracy and is breathing
so I would say the Turkish democracy is
providing to be amazingly resilient this
shows the high turnout in the election
but turkey does not fulfill the basic
principles of a democratic election for
sure as well Central political and
social actors are in prison
against judgments of the European Court
of Human Rights media freedom is
severely restricted and there's a
climate of self-censorship so turkey has
a long way from Far a fair election
campaign conditions and I really would
like to underline this because some
people say what has it to do with the
with the elections and with the election
campaign and our observation we have
judgments from the I would call it
higher scrud in Europe the European
Court of Human Rights and I'm really
here to call the authorities in the
country which one ever we will see to
release those one who are in prison and
where is a very clear judgment from the
European Court of Human Rights and the
most important and prominent examples
are Osman Kabbalah and because this has
to do something with the Democratic
constitution in the situation and in the
in the country I have also to remind the
Turkish government on the
recommendations of the Venice commission
and Greco and other bodies of the
Council of Europe we spoke already about
the question of media freedom I always
used when I go to election campaign to
switch on the TV even if I don't
understand the language but I get an
impression and when I switch on trt
Harbor maybe you are here I have really
an impression that the
the current president was very much seen
in TV and we had a lot of talks
together with air took the radio and
television High Council the
pre-electrical mission now in the
mission and to today I don't really
understand the rules very much and for
sure it brings the kind of situation of
self-censorship into the country and
this has to concern out again there was
a really high turnout and a January free
access for voters to go to the polling
stations yesterday although there were
some situations I faced one myself or
what was not very easy because people
were very nervous and this was my my
assessment but anyhow it was possible to
vote we had restrictions for sure very
much for the hdp and for some
politicians we have to mention it and we
mention it in several reports of the
Council of Europe
what was a matter of concern was really
the situation yesterday evening and uh
and in the night where it was not really
clear how the situation was going on and
what was was really happening I think is
more clear today and really this I have
to ask the Supreme electoral council
with a very special method in this
country to be as much as transparent as
possible because I think was much more
transparency it would be able to prevent
such a situation again thank you very
much thank you very much for having us
here in this situation we try to do our
job our mandate impartial as possible
and thank you very much for the good
cooperation
many things
who heads the delegation from the osce
PA
thank you Katia and thank you all for
joining us especially after a long
election day and night
so I want to express my deep
appreciation to my colleagues special
coordinator Michael link head of pace
delegation Frank
and for the lyrics and also Ambassador
Peterson for their excellent cooperation
throughout our election observation
mission
uh my name is Farah Academy and I am a
senator in the Dutch Senate I'm a member
of the osce Parliamentary assembly
it was an honor for me to help a team of
98 osce parliamentary assembly observers
from 26 different countries who came
together to observe the elections in
your beautiful country
I want to highlight that our teams were
warmly welcomed across the country not
just in Ankara but also in regions like
Istanbul Ismail one and the Arabic
and personally I had the privilege of
observing the process in jankaya and
elmadak and I extend my sincere
gratitude to everyone for their warm
Hospital hospitality
unfortunately I must address the
regrettable decision by the Turkish
government
to deny accreditations to two
parliamentarians from Sweden and Denmark
why we respect a country's right to
control access to polling stations it is
important that the invitation to our
assembly to observe elections does not
influence the composition of the
observation missions
this decision based on the
parliamentarian's public opinion is
particularly disheartening
ladies and gentlemen I want to Echo the
statements made by my colleagues Mr Link
and Mr schwaba
in emphasizing that despite the
availability of political alternatives
for Turkish people
these elections have seen unfair
advantages enjoyed by the incumbent
president and ruling parties
we are yet to know the final results
but in the event of a second
presidential round we will pay close
attention to ensuring a Level Playing
Field in our observations
throughout our mission we closely
monitored every step of the election day
process
from the opening of polling stations to
the voting and Counting
the polling stations Revisited had a
remarkable voter turnout
showing the strong Democratic spirits of
the Turkish people
I commend the dedication of everyone
involved including poll workers and
Civil Society
it is crucial
to address the significant
underrepresentation of women in Turkish
politics
I urge the next government Parliament
and political parties to take concrete
actions to ensure equal participation of
women in the country's political life
this can include introduce introducing
laws that guarantee an equal number of
male and female candidates on electoral
lists
I also want to express my appreciation
for the determination shown by those who
despite the challenges caused by recent
earthquakes made the effort to travel to
their damaged homes and vote
however it's concerning that the voter
turnout in earthquake affected areas was
lower
indicating that many people couldn't
vote
in case of a second round of the
presidential election we hope concrete
measures will be taken to ensure
everyone can exercise their right to
vote
the government should also take
additional steps to support individuals
facing difficulties during such critical
circumstances ladies and gentlemen thank
you for your attention and of course I
am ready to answer any question you may
have
thank you very much and last but not
least from the podium we turn to
Ambassador Jan Peterson who heads the
mission of the international Observer
Mission from ODS side
thank you very much and enjoy my
colleagues in welcome you
all of you and thank you for your
interest in Ababa work
first of all I would like to Begin by
thanking the Turkish authorities for
inviting us to observe
and I'd also like to thank our partners
in the international election
observation Mission from the OC
parliamentary assembly as well as the
Parliamentary assembly of the Council of
Europe for their excellent cooperation
and especially our coordinator Mr Lee
before I go into our findings in more
detail I'd like to emphasize the fact
that I and a team of election experts
have been in Turkey since late March
with a 28 long-term observers arriving
just a week later to observe around the
country
in this period of six weeks we have
therefore had the opportunity to observe
the run-up to the elections closely and
to hold numerous meetings with officials
as well as representatives of the
election authorities political parties
civil society and the media
further 213 short-term observers joined
us last week
enabling us to make a comprehensive
statistical assessment of the voting
process on the election day
allow me then to go into a few
points in more detail
first of all I would like to
congratulate the people of turkey for
their Democratic Spirit which was
illustrated by the high turnout on
Election Day
voters had a choice to make between
genuine political alternatives
and the campaign period was mostly
peaceful with most candidates
campaigning freely
at the same time the election
administration led by the Supreme
election Council worked efficiently and
mostly within the Safety Human demons
this was no small feat given the
challenges of the devastating
earthquakes that the truth is complete
just a few months ago
these are all positive elements in the
process running up to yesterday's
election and I'm glad to be able to draw
your attention to them here today
however
there are other elements of our
assessment that are rejected to be more
negative
to the election Administration
notwithstanding its efficiency it worked
its work was marked by the by lack of
transparency in adequate complication
and concern over Independence
not only were sessions of that Supreme
Election Commission and mid-level
relation Council not held in public but
the Supreme election Council also fails
fail to publish most of his decisions
despite the new obligation to do so
another area of concern was the pressure
on opposition connotations and parties
which was a series of special to the
participation in the election
the green left party faith is widespread
indignation and even the rest of its
supporters which goes against
International standards and severeign
opportunities
long-standing concern about the respect
for fundamental freedoms of the assembly
Association and expression which are all
key to democracy we're not delicate
during the election period
and almost also the Constitution
guarantees the independence of the
Judiciary many of the people to whom
this vote from across a wide spectrum of
society continue to raise concerns that
this Independence is not being from
health
and then um
a final point an important point I'd
like to make from our long-term
observation concerns the media
media coverage of the campaign
in our assessment the freedom of
expression and the media also protected
by the Constitution
is rated by a number of laws
the reasons criminalization of
disseminational false information
the fact that websites are frequently
blocked on an online content removed and
the ongoing analysts and prosecutions of
dollars for the league in freedom of
expression
unfortunately we also noted that until
something broadcasting clearly favored
the ruling parties and the candidates
during the campaign despite his
constitutional obligation to remain
impartial
the majority field Providence National
Theater channels we wanted to let us
talk about observation but it also
clearly biased to what the ruling
parties in their conference
I'd like to make a fine point of the
elections election day itself
voting day was mostly peaceful also
there were a number of incidents in and
around police stations
all those processors generally well
organized
on service reported that says God such
as a ceiling on by the boxes and
verifying voter ID
in addition in some public stations
the secrecy of the world
and family and Reporting their
frequences well fortunately or half of
the polling stations were not fully
accessible for persons with disabilities
these are some of the key points from
other observations which I know had
mentioned that the game already in March
however there are many more points in
our report with with the initial
findings of the internal the
international Southern Nation
and I would recommend that you take a
copy together with the press release on
your way out
and before I finish a helpful thanks to
the team working with me hidden on cars
and as the long and short government
surface spread out across the country
and thank you again for coming and I as
well related to answer your questions
thank you
who do this observation issue
methodology exercise in so many places
all over the OC area and the Council of
Europe area and therefore thanks to all
of them you will see and read a lot and
what they have gathered in terms of
extremely important information in the
report which has been receiving us ideas
thank you
many times there's some time now and for
questions I would just like to emphasize
that what you're all welcoming here
today this is a press conference and we
will only be taking questions from the
media if I can be grateful if you could
win by introducing yourself and your
media Outlet before asking your
questions we'd also have simultaneous
translation and so if you like you are
welcome to pick your questions
is
thanks for having us my name is
from German television art
my question is there have been
accusations by the name of the social
politics regarding
um for example in the polling stations
where it came out
there have been people from the app
party asking to count again again again
and again what do you know about this
and secondly they have been accusations
for example made by
one of the candidates who say when it
comes to the votes of the Turkish people
really abroad they're happy it has
information about manipulation these two
questions
whoever wants one of the answers I would
like to have a shot if possible the
other question
already that there was a room
um for rumors suspicions and
verification yesterday late evening and
in the night and it has to do and I had
to do with the question that it was not
really transparent what was going on and
I really would welcome in such a
situation that the Supreme electoral
part could clarify how they publish
outcomes and how they from and what and
how they form about the rules as well so
we we hear about such robots we
and social media we have teams who are
witnesses as well and there were
Witnesses in some police stations where
there was a question to recount again
and again and again not only outcome was
100 clear
I don't know I'm my impressionist today
it's quite clear but yesterday it was a
very uh not clear situation and if the
outcome maybe would be another one there
were some suspicions for what purpose it
was going on and again with kind of more
transparency I think you can prevent
such a situations and one of us asked
already for a possible second round for
more transparencies
privilege so far then I would like to
underline you to welcome this as well
if I just want to answer
anyway as I said my way out of study we
have of course
service in many of the following
stations
and even if we can give any of our
different kind of reports backup the
important thing is what is a general
impression or what has happened and our
general immigration is that
the voting process will also generally
well organized and assessed
positively
during the vote counts they were
considered and also observed and and
but I will not go into specific issues I
think that just give you these more
General General observations because
that is what is the Heatwave trigger
together with colleagues at that very
place where in this conference center a
giant one you know it better than I do
where all the votes the palace from
across are being counted or have been
already accounted I was there for
several hours I was watching
um intensively and I have to say also
also knowing how this question has been
handled in the past sometimes with with
sometimes no possibility at all to watch
the process
neither for The Observers for
international ones nor for political
partial service I would really have to
say that this term was a step forward
the allegations I heard them but we also
heard and we intensity talked to
political party representatives in all
parties about their assessment of this
process and overall they have sequence
to us that they don't see their large
issue of manipulation
also to accomplish these little boxes
whether they are coming from abroad so
I'll see you there in this part I see a
progress and clear progress in the right
direction nevertheless this is important
that still can be improved but I don't
see a lot of room for for for
manipulation there and honestly the
process of counting there I saw hundreds
of party representatives of different
parties including of course CHP and
Greenleaf party in that Center there so
I think that is a step forward but let's
see this certainly something which we
will also address
in the Russian further findings as you
know there were always also final
reports after the full appeals process
in an election and there is something
which is which is
in a super perfect way but again we see
note there was a manipulation in that
company
thank you thank you very much
right
now
thank you very much
you also mentioned a relatively low
turnouts in the quick hit process can
you please elaborate on that do you have
any numbers and what do you think caused
this lack of diamond transport or what
inside the presence thinking
yeah exactly
um actually we have some numbers which
are of course official numbers provided
by by the authorities and it shows a few
points less actually presence of or
playing out by by voters in the
earthquake affected areas and the reason
I think is obvious
it is a
the number of the people who left
the areas because of the actual impact
of earthquake
um even we don't have a really very
precise numbers but it is more than
convenience
on the same time and the people who
really registered
themselves in new actually places
and were able to vote in other places
because
it was something more than 300 000. so
the remaining people if they wanted to
vote and they had to go back
to their cities and villages
and that's obviously a very huge
undertaking popular
and maybe did that and that's really
very important to emphasize that because
that means how important it is for
Turkish people to vote
but unfortunately
yeah maybe didn't because it
it's quite really a lot of Investments
and that's actually the point that we
make and we say there was no legal
action obstacle for them to vote and
however
the practicalities were really very huge
and required
additional
Investments and time and also emotional
emotional burden for them to go back and
to vote and we hope sincerely that for
if there is a second
second round of the president election
that there
'll be better measures to accommodate
people so that they can exercise their
rights
can I just take this opportunity to
advertise our report because there
we have presented you with a 20-page
report and the report contains quite a
lot of facts and figures so if you you
you may have some of the answers in the
report so please also read it after the
difference content it might be it might
be useful
thank you thank you very much
uh we see very quickly uh postings on
social media of election officials
standing out of the ballot for the
ruling party
one of these
previous elections the person holding
the cell phone camera was a woman and
you heard her saying to the official
what you're doing is illegal
before God
now this was never followed up
the Supreme electoral Council doesn't
see
the appears not to see any obligation to
consume uh irregularities
I think it sort of brings that job to
the police and what is the base fluid or
not is
a matter of conscientiousness of the
local police Commander anyway what I'm
asking is abusing the Supreme electoral
Council should have a unit where the
adults investigate and pursue or engaged
who needs to get them to pursue clear
irregularities
[Music]
holds meetings that Defenders address or
public should be president
what do you mean by greater transparency
Council thank you
a couple of things first of all that all
the decisions are
published as a livestock then that the
decisions are and make the reason for
decisions are given and actually I don't
think it is
decided and as they didn't create a lot
of trust if you are open with everything
so that is why I put some emphasis on
transparency I think we actually
everyone will tell again from that
uh you also asked about the previous
elections well I was not observing the
last election so so I cannot comment on
issues like that and when it comes to
what we think should be done for the
future I think that there are pretty
early days to say so just to inform you
we have the two stage approach first of
all we have these preliminary findings
which actually comes just hours after we
have seen the uh that the
voting has ended
that we are starting to do count the
votes and actually we don't have the
officials yet but still we have a
primary import out but then after this
after the reporter discipline the report
has been out we have a two to three
months period where we really do go deep
more deeply into the issues and come up
with recommendations so in our next next
report the final report you will also
have a lot of recommendations on how to
improve the process
for 40 years I know that it is just now
that you haven't been really big public
interest so perhaps I could advertise
our next report into the three months
time you will find a lot of interesting
stuff in there I can assure you
um if I may add
um actually on the issue of whether you
should the Supreme Election Commission
who should be the body who actually
investigates
all possible irregularities I think this
is something that it has to be clarified
which part is related to irregularity is
actually in relation to the election law
at the part that they have the authority
on that and which part is a kind of
criminal activity which is of course a
normal police work I would say but in
any case the important thing is that
the the the the follow-up happens and
really enough investigations happen and
of course you can understand that we
don't comment on specific video or you
know a specific
points in social media but what we heard
from interlocutors and from our
observation we know that the fake news
and also this very polarized language
inflammatory language has been part of
the problem during the campaigns so but
this is I think something that in
Turkish politics really should be
experience on that and a decision
how
a on the transparency I
say we ourselves we
had really a huge interest making a
supreme Election Commission we invited
also them to actually come and visit us
and have a conversation with us and
explain us the process because they are
the highest a body executionally but
also Judiciary with judicial authorities
in in
actually in the election process so a
very very very important
body in this country and unfortunately
they
didn't make themselves available to meet
us
we
neutral in Hillary that I said
[Music]
I would have two questions I didn't I
couldn't really understand your answer
to my colleagues question on recounting
do you see the recruiting
because the opposition the
considered the recounting again and
again as a way of blocking a story of
delaying the results I couldn't really
understand if you were considering this
as not really having an impact on that
and my second question
says if I know it well turkey has a long
way from Fair election campaign
conditions
is this also what you would say on
overall the election process because you
said some negative points and positive
points I didn't say anything on overall
direction process thank you
starting starting with the last one
um no you know in our mind is always to
look into the conditions
of an electoral procedure and the
environment and to understand the
situation in the country you know was
hearing as well but the council room has
a lot of different values to look into
the situation of turkey and we don't
don't come just in the country and say a
little bit but we have a lot of reports
and we based on this report that you
have to
to look into the situation you look you
have to look at the election procedures
on the election day and
as we describe it
it was in a way a quite good working
election procedure with some problems
yeah there but overall
for a country like turkey where I would
describe the environment for Democratic
elections as difficult and challenging
it's interesting that it's possible to
hold on such an election with such a
higher turnout and really was a
possibility to to change something and
to vote on something on Election Day is
very interesting but in the Democratic
environment for sure it's difficult and
we spoke about it I don't want to say
everything again and there are some
preconditions for a democratic elections
and we don't see them really enough in
this country this is what what I said
about this or what I mean about this the
question of
um of recounting
um you know when you look at this class
because recounting for sure is in the
rules
to the Lord you can ask for recounting
by recounting is in a way I think the
meaning of recounting is the right of
let's say a minority aware to check
again if there is a
right decision and it's a right counting
but if you have an impression that the
purpose is something else
to maybe delay the figures in the
evening then I will say it's it's not
used in the right way this is what I saw
the believing I was
looking into myself with the police
stations we had colleagues in our own
team from the Council of Europe who
reported about this that for no reason
there was counting and counting again
but finally let's say from the
perspective of today I would say since
all the opposition parties accept the
outcome in a way of the selection is
nothing we have to discuss due to this
election very much but for sure if it
comes to the second round
we need a kind of let's say
clarification how to deal with such a
situation and again
the concerns were a little bit
um to do something with what we
discussed about the transparency or the
election approach procedure and how the
Supreme election card is working so I
really ask and urge the Supreme and
natural crowd to be as transparent as
possible to even prevent there should
not be any suspicion but they should
prevent that it could see that's not
impartial enough and there is just one
thing
to do so it's it's transparency
but actually it has not been is not part
of our report
s something which we have to help with
so I need simply to study this a little
bit more if I should give you a
reasonable answer to your your question
uh I hope you understand that there were
quite a lot of elements to consider
during many
disposal but as I said this has not been
reported back to and overall impression
is that there were some irregularities
some problems with with accounting but
uh not beyond that
punch
in the back and then move forward
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
maybe I should add on the issue of media
in our preliminary
findings you will find two pages
actually exactly around the media and
and we're very excited data because
luckily over here has a very good medium
monitoring department they have monitors
actually the media and we will read in
detail with the percentages and numbers
in quantity and then you will see that
there has been a very
you will see there is a clear picture of
access when it comes to on the one side
the ruling part is an incumbent
president and
the oppositional
thank you very much
children from our community agency I'm
doing the process did you face any
challenges about getting contact with
political parties if so those are clear
share your
you too
but perhaps I should start on this
because we have the as I said six or
weeks at our disposal so um we have been
in touch with many many
I mean many democrators parties ngos
government
agencies media so we have covered quite
a lot of course we
sometimes it takes a little time to
schedule meetings but uh
when you're powering the campaign we
understand that it takes time before we
can have our our meeting so I would say
that we have
quite a lot of meetings I think we when
we go to a close election day we have a
pretty good picture of what happened so
we are actually very grateful to all the
parties for for meeting with us and some
other really high level people who we
understand that they spent the time
campaigning instead of meeting us but we
we're meeting with a very very informed
age so
I just recognize as as one of the
positive elements of our six weeks after
now
thank you very much yes please
thank you again you're hungry Alex uh
what do you already answered the
question I still have something about
being also abroad because not all the
boats have been counted yet therefore
there is no final result and if I
understand that correct me if I'm if I'm
wrong
technically it's still possible that
thanks for those both abroad album can
reaching and in that case there is no
second round are you prepared for that
scenario and do you have the possibility
to observe the whole process until the
final result announced
the results
but I will Clearly say
some minutes ago the second announced
around officially with the integrated
results and of course what you consider
better of course our team stays here and
of course the job is not done continuous
well actually it's just uh what Mr Lee
said that of course we have to prepare
to observe the second round as one so of
course this has been one of the main
questions for a long time so this is
actually not a new development we are
flexible
and I can add that it is indeed now
announced the result and also the second
round presidential election for 28th of
May and osce parliamentary assembly is
prepared to again observe the second job
manager
may I just had to say that for sure we
are very important as an international
automation missions but as you know we
can just deal some parts of the country
and it's very very
not just to see how high the turnout was
in this election but to see how many
young people who are prepared to be
observous into the country just to care
and to fight and to deal with in
democracy in this country from which
party ever is of totally different
representatives from Partners from the
Civil Society and finally they are the
ones who make sure that the Integrity of
the election procedures are respected
thank you very much indeed I don't think
there are any more questions from the
floor so I'll check to see whether
there's anything that's coming over soon
see no questions from Zoom so if there
are no further questions thank you very
much indeed I would go through one of my
colleagues being reported both language
versions as well as the press release
are outside on the table and you can
pick them up as you go out and they are
also available on odia's website thank
you very much
thank you